[Music]
everyone welcome to again Sports III
2018 coverage I'm Randy this is
Alessandra we're gonna talk about Metro
Exodus right now we actually got to play
quite a bit of this even before e3 but
would be the embargoed since then yeah
we've just been hanging on yeah waiting
until right now to actually tell you
what we think about it I think we played
like close to an hour of them yeah yeah
we got to like you know really just dive
into like the the sort of the new
setting which is a big change for the
series because uh for the most part
they've always been like within like
tunnels and like you know dilapidated in
like you know subway systems and this is
the first time where we're actually for
the most part of the game sticking out
onto the surface and you know it's it's
a quite an adjustment at least it's not
quite an open world so you know we
talked to some of the developers and you
know it's not like a big open world like
you'd find and you know Red Dead or
Zelda or something but they are quite
sort of like expansive areas and there's
a few that you move through as the game
progresses right yeah and the first one
that we that we played was you know like
you started off in the train which was
blockaded and basically I think your job
in that area was to try and repair that
train and then move forward well they
refer to them as sand boxes like you
know these are basically they're not
quite open-world areas where there's
like different like you know systemic
things happening at once they all sort
of mingle together you're basically
going through it how you choose we stuck
with a story mission for the most part
which was to sort of confront this sort
of a cult which was sort of like held up
in like this sort of church or that was
basically out in water so once we got
out there of course things went south
and you know we had to shoot our way out
and that's when we you know got you know
really comfortable with the Metro sort
of style of shooting which is you know
incredibly hardcore and like you know
very difficult
it is very hardcore and I was going to
say that you know the despite the move
to this sort of like semi open world
that is an as Alinea you know the
difficulty in Metro is still there and I
guess difficulty is kind of a strange
turn to you because you know this was
our first time with it so you know
personally I found it a little bit tough
just in terms of a resource man yeah and
that's always been a hallmark of the
game though but I bullets so many times
in this thing this that sort of survival
aspect has always been a part of Metro
but it's much more pronounced in this
one because you're crafting on the fly
you're basically trying to find as many
like you know scraps of metal and other
resources like where you can like you
know cuz there is that sandbox element
where you can just basically explore and
like maybe find like old train like cars
like maybe they'll have something of
value for you but uh an interesting
thing you have is that your backpack you
know you can basically customize like
your weapons on the fly and nephew and
that's the big new thing yeah that's
right yeah and it came with like a
pretty cool animation well yeah you know
take out your backpack roll it out and
you can see all the stuff that you you
could actually impact and you know that
was great because yeah I did find a
couple of components and we managed to
actually improve some weapons while I
was actually running around fearing for
my life at every second yeah I mean it
looks really cool when you pull it out
but also it leaves you open which is the
challenge like you know cuz you have to
pick your moments where you want to
basically sort of examine your inventory
and see what you have but you know yo
you always have to be mindful of where
you are so there are several safe zones
around the map for the most part you're
gonna be away and out in the field and
you know you gotta be really smart about
how you play yeah and that's a great way
to use it I think you need to be you
know on point while you're playing this
game it's not a game to see it seems
that you know
rewards you for you know food for
wavering attention you actually need to
you know have a plan in your head you
know figure out where you want to go and
how you're gonna get there
who knew the Russian wilderness could be
so dangerous in the post apocalypse it's
not a great place to be I think but you
know I think there's a lot of potential
in this game I'm very sorry about seeing
more you know unfortunately did get
pushed back oh yeah we sort of got a
sense of why it was pushed back because
there was some very notable technical
hiccups like the framerate was a little
inconsistent to say the least and load
times were took a while especially for
me because I kept dying so like you know
when it took a minute to load back into
my checkpoint you know that was a little
frustrating for me and like you know
that made me want to try to try to do
better in the next time I you know I got
into the game so you know I think what
we saw
you know already looked great and you
know we would the extra months out there
you know hopefully you know like using
to to improve a lot of this stuff you
know I think that the game seems to be
in pretty good shape right yeah it could
be something really cool and it's a big
change for the series which is always
exciting okay so that's it for metro
Exodus we have a lot more on this game
on the site so check it out and
everything else for e3 check out games
for young
right there but I heard you and wouldn't
believe you